مسلسل عمله نادره دراما مصريه صعيديه فيها
منافسه على السلطه والثروه والصراع بين
عائلتين بسبب زواج بيصير بين طرفين
والمسلسل من بطوله نيللي كريم وجمال
سليمان ومجموعه من الفنانين الاخرين ومنهم
الفنان هشام عاشور هشام اللي عرفوا الناس
كلاعب رمضان الماضي بموهبه تمثيليه وشارك
في اكثر من عمل اللي هم يوتر مسلسل يوتيرن
ومسلسل احلام سعيده كمان السنه هشام صعيدي
في عمله نادره وبيلعب دور عصام اللي بيحب
بنت الحاج عبد الجبار اللي بيقوم بدوره
الفنان الكبير جمال سليمان لكن قصه الحب
هذه بشوبا مشاكل وصراعات عائليه جسيم
بنتعرف عليها حلقه بعد ثانيه مسلسل عمله
نادره مختلف تماما بالنسبه لهشام فاولا
لانه هذه المره اللي بيخوض فيها تجربه
دراما الصعيديه مثل ما قلنا وثانيا لانه
هذا اول عمل فني بيشوفوا الجمهور وبيجمعوا
مع زوجته الفنانه نيللي كريم هشام اللي
اشتغلوا سوا مسلسل اسمه روز وليلى من 10
حلقات لكن لسه ما عرضه منتظر عرضه على
منصه شاهد لكن بعد رمضان على العموم احنا
معنا من القاهره الفنان هشام عاشور اهلا
فيك معنا يا هشام كل عام وانت بالف خير
وانتم طيبين ورمضان كريم عليكم وعلى
المسلمين في كل حته في العالم كل سنه
وانتم طيبين وانت طيب يا رب هشام خلاص
الان نقدر نقدر نقول انه الفنان هشام
الممثل هشام خلاص هذه صارت اسمك الوظيفي
الجديد او مهنتك
طبعا ميه في الميه خلاص يعني لاعب سكواش
سابقا وفنان حاليا
كل حاجه لها وقتها خلصت وبقى لي فتره مركز
جامد في التمثيل الحمد لله طيب حلو خلينا
نبتدي بعمله نادره يعني صراحه الواحد لسه
بادئ يدخل السوق والكلام هذا كله يعني
تحدي كبير انك تلعب شيء في بيئه صعيديه
يعني
من اصعب الحاجات يعني يعني تمثيل بتاع
الصعيدي والبادي لانجوتش بتاع الصعيدي
واللغه نفسها مش مش اسهل حاجه يعني ولكن
الحمد لله كان معنا الاستاذ عبد النبي
الهواري اخويا الكبير يعني مصحح اللغه عمل
معنا شغل بصراحه كلنا غير عادي
والناس بعد ما قرات المسلسل وحثت بحلاوه
المسلسل كله قرر ان هو يركز ويدوس جامد
قوي في موضوع اللغه وبعد ما دخلنا المسلسل
وشفنا الصعيدي عامل ازاي حبيناه حب يعني
غير عادي يعني مشاعر الصعيدي فظيعه يعني
ايش تحس اكبر غير اللغه والاشياء دي كلها
ايش اكبر التحديات اللي حاسسها في هذه
الشخصيه يعني ليش حبيت انك تلعب هذه
الشخصيه تحديدا
بصي هي الشخصيه الوحيده اللي في المسلسل
يعني المفروض اللي هو الاستاذ المتعلم
اللي هو صوت الحق اللي هو صوت العقل في
وسط ناس كتيره جدا بتتخانق وبتتعارك على
على حاجات
يعني مش مش مهمه حاجات يعني مش قصدي مش
مهمه قصدي حاجات حاجات مش كويسه يعني
اتكلم على مخدرات وبنتكلم على سلاح
والاستاذ المتعلم محطوط في وسط دي ودي
حاجات بتحصل في الصعيد لما كنا في الصعيد
واحنا بنصور قعدنا كتير وسمعنا وشفنا ناس
كثيره جدا اهاليهم بيكبروهم وبيطلعوهم
بيعلموهم وبعدين بعد ما بيعلموهم بيلاقوا
نفسهم برده محطوطين في نفس القصه دي
محطوطين في النص في وسط مخدرات وفي وسط
سلاح وفي وسط حاجات كده وبيضطروا ان هم
يتعاملوا مع الموقف يعني كيف وجدت العمل
مع زوجتك طبعا النجمه الكبيره نيللي كريم
طبعا بنوجه لها تحيه بس يعني عاده مش سهل
الواحد يعني يشتغل مع يعني شريكه
والله نيللي دي وحش
ههه
تمثيل ما قصدك وحش ثاني نروح نورطك على
الهوا يا هشام وما ترجع البيت ههه
لا وحشه تمثيل طبعا واللي هي عملته ده
بصراحه يعني انا انا لحد لحد اسبوع قبل ما
نبدا ما كنتش يعني مصدق او شايف ان هي
تقدر تعمل حاجه زي كده لحد ما يعني ده
كاميرا
اتحولت يعني انا كنت عارف طول عمري عارف
ان هي جامده جدا جدا جدا بس بعد اللي هي
عملته هنا وازاي ماسكه الشخصيه وازاي
ماسكه مشاعر الشخصيه الصعيدي والتون بتاع
اللغه
وبتمثل بعنيها صعيدي وبتمثل بجسمها يعني
انا بصراحه شايف ان هي عامله دور هيبقى من
اكبر واهم الادوار بالنسبه لها واحنا ما
بنتقابلش كتير قوي في المسلسل احنا خطين
مختلفين
بس يعني يعني تمام تمام
في الكواليس التصوير
بنشوف بعض الكواليس التصوير بس عايز اقول
لك يعني مسلسل يعني احنا اكثر عيلتنا
شغالين اكثر مع العيله بتاعتي مع استاذ
كمال ابو رقيه العظيم استاذ كمال ابو ريا
حبيبي
ومعنا طبعا استاذ احمد فهيم عبقري برضو
عمل طرق جميل وميزو اللي هو محمد علي لازم
تشوف عشان تفهم الصراع اللي داير بين
العوائل في المسلسل يعني دراما شديده طيب
بس اكيد هشام بتسمع الكلام حق انه هو
مفروض على المسلسل لانه زوج النجمه وما
الكلام ده كله بيزعجك الكلام ده
والله بصي هي القصه كلها بتبقى انت انت
عارفه انت مين ولا لا انا بالنسبه لي انا
الحمد لله ذاكرت كتير جدا تمثيل في امريكا
وعملت حاجه صغيره فاليوت مع ايس تي في
فيلم اسمه وعارف انا امكانياتي كممثل
هذه النكته يمكن لازم توضحها هشام انك انت
موضوع التمثيل بادئ من 2013 في امريكا من
اصلا قبل ما تتزوج نيللي والكلام ده كله
اه طبعا انا ابتديت
9 سنين وبعدين رحت
كتير جدا سنه ونص في الوقت بتاع الكورونا
وانا كنت مستعد تماما وبعدين لما جيت مصر
قعدت ذاكرت طبعا عشان مش مختلف بالعربي
وكده وانا انا بالنسبه لي قصه
انا انا بحب انا انا بعبد القصه دي انا
بعبدها لان انا بالنسبه لي ده فن التاثير
في البني ادم وانا بالنسبه لي تاثير في
البني ادم بالايجاب هو ده اللي بيشجيني
وده اللي انا ببقى دايما بدور عليه فانا
بشتغل على نفسي كل يوم بذاكر كل يوم في
فيديوهات معينه عندي مدارس بشتغل معاه
عندي مدرس مصر العصامي بشتغل معاه فعندي
حاجه انا شغال على نفسي كل يوم لان انا
عايز في الاخر ان انا بعرف وانا بعمل
الكلام ده اروح هوليود ان شاء الله
ما بقدرش اوقف شغل على نفسي انا شغال على
نفسي كل يوم الحمد لله فانت تارك انه مجال
للاعمال انه حتى تكون خارجيه يعني
في احدث مقابلاتها قالت انك انت ممثل كويس
بس ما عندكش خبره كبيره لانه الخبره بتجري
من كثره الاعمال بتتفق معاها في هذا
الكلام ولا بتحس انها انتقدتك من تحت لتحت
احنا جايين احنا احنا فاعلين خير احنا
جايين نهدي النفوس يعني بس انه
فهي تقول كده على طول عبقري يعني الناس
هتمسكها طبعا
في كل الاحوال مش هتخلص
اي حاجه تانيه غير ان انا افضل اشتغل على
نفسي عشان اقدر اعمل ده نحفان يا هشام يا
سؤال اعتراضي كده
بتمرن بتمرن جامد جدا بقى لي حبه فعلا
وبعمل شويه تمارين وحاجات عشان لو حاجه
اكشن جايه الفتره الجايه لازم جاهز يعني
لانه حسيت كده من وشك انك نازل نازل وزنك
كم كيلو نازل لا لازم كتير اوه والله كله
رياضه ولا فيه دايت كله رياضه كل ده طبعا
تظبيط اكل يعني
رياضه يعني الحمد لله العزيمه بتاعتي صحيت
تاني يعني انا بقى لي فتره كنت نايم
وكده
بس الحمد لله دلوقتي انا راجع تاني يعني
بتمرن كويس قوي الحمد لله لا ممتاز ممتاز
احنا طبعا بنتمنى لك التوفيق وعارفين انه
لسه عندك كمان يعني نازله اعمال قادمه
يعني ان شاء الله حتحقق فيها المزيد من
النجاح شكرا لك يا هشام وان شاء الله
دائما بالتوفيق وسعيده انه نحن قابلناك
وتعرفنا على روحك
الحلوه معانا هنا على الهواء
تسلم كل سنه وانتم طيبين وانت طيب كان
معنا من القاهره الفنان هشام عاشور
[موسيقى]